[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Поділля,
село Букатинка]
♪ [лунає українська народна музика] ♪
Це Людмила.
Вона заманила мене сюди
і тримає вже 39 років, скоро буде 40.
Зустрілися в Коростені на практиці.
Вона була підстрижена «під нуль».
Ось така дивна дівчина, давала читати вірші.
А потім каже: «Слухай, невже немає
якихось коренів національної скульптури?».
Це був 1978 рік.
Так як поезію, кіно всі ж шукали.
На що ж можна спертися, чи є у нас корені?
Коли — так, є корені.
І ми їдемо сюди.
Я каменотесом в кар'єрі працюю.
І так почалося: перший рік, потім 1978.
Наступного року вже буде 40 років
[Олексій Альошкін
Скульптор, художник]
відданих саме творчості і творчості з каменя.
Заради цього ми полишили Київ і Мінськ.
Люда — Мінськ, я Київ.
Бо головне — це природа,
а не те, що ми понабудували.
[лунають ритмічні стуки
на ударному інструменті]
[вигукує зі скелі]
[звук відлунювання]
Пішла луна.
Кожен подих
віддається в лісі.
Сходить сонце
і там заходить.
Цей рух сонця
спостерігали тут 9000 років тому
перші поселенці на цих місцях —
найдавніші поселення буго-дністровської культури,
яка була між Бугом і Дністром.
[лунають ритмічні стуки
на ударному інструменті]
Цим скелям 800 мільйонів років.
Верхнім 250 мільйонів, а цим 800.
Коли життя взагалі не було,
тут було дно прадавнього моря.
Але життя не було.
Не було ще вапнякових рештків,
які скріплюють верхні шари.
Є в інших народів різні раритети —
Стіна Плачу тощо.
Так само і в Україні є прекрасні місця,
де можна доторкнутися і увібрати енергію
прадавніх тисячоліть, мільйонів років.
Тільки треба уміти і бажати цього,
відчувати, налаштованим бути на цю хвилю.
♪ [лунає повільна мелодія
на духовому та ударному інструментах] ♪
Чути, як літає комашка.
Звісно, краще було б,
якби люди жили тут.
За 40 років багато пішло.
А хати лишилися.
Я намагаюся зробити в них
якийсь музей, розмалювати,
наповнити чимось.
Просто, щоб ця хата збереглася.
Головне — початок.
А потім будуть й люди.
Дасть Бог, діти, онуки знайдуть.
Все, що навколо, — можна перетворити.
Навіть такі от
залишені будиночки равликів.
Можна їх прикрасити
та зробити витвір мистецтва.
Тобто в неживе додавати живе.
Як той свисток:
глина нежива,
а можна додати в неї...
♪ [насвистує ритмічну мелодію] ♪
Коли людина творить, відбувається
величезний прилив енергії.
І не треба нічого іншого.
Світлі думки — і настрій буде хороший.
Як тільки потрапляють «віруси»:
погані думки, погані хвилі,
тоді ясно, що людина не творитиме.
Якщо казати «Я класний!», «Я хороший!»,
«Я українець!», «Я творець!»,
то можна творити найпростіше — дітей.
Це природно.
Найкращі скульптури —це діти.
А ми відкладаємо:
«Ми будемо ці скульптури робити,
а потім дітей».
Треба робити все зараз.
Ми здебільше живемо
або минулим, або майбутнім,
а в реальному часі не перебуваємо.
♪ [лунає енергійна музика, яку водночас грають
на ударному інструменті, співають та вигукують] ♪
[удари стихають та змінюють частоту]
Почнемо
з пам'ятного знаку Казимиру Малевичу.
Він за татом і мамою був поляк,
але сам казав: «Я українець!»
У кожного свій чорний квадрат.
Кожен бачить в цьому квадраті своє.
Один бачить одне,
другий — інше.
Тут теж пам'ятник поважній людині,
Джорджу Харрісону.
Наприкінці життя він став
своєрідним філософом «Бітлз».
І він написав:
«Зачекати може все,
окрім пошуків Бога
та любові одне до одного».
А це — козак.
Козак перекладається «вільна людина».
Він складається з пташок.
Як пташки розлетяться —
козака не буде.
Суть його: свобода, воля.
♪ [лунають ритмічні стуки
на ударному інструменті] ♪
Капіталізм так захопив людей.
Оця «гонитьба за баблом»
— це шлях в нікуди.
Люди не розуміють, що ми всі — ціле.
Я, Іван, Петро — всі.
Природа, дерево, вода —
ми всі одне ціле,
а не окреме.
Не можна тут отруїти воду
і жити окремо.
Це неможливо.
Як ти щось скоїв,
потім тобі воно повернеться просто.
Не тобі, так другу.
Головне — бути щасливим.
Це найважливіше.
Колись одна приїхала і тричі перепитує:
«Ти щасливий?»
«Та щасливий».
На другий день знову питає, бо не вірить:
«Невже тут можна бути щасливим?»
«Так, я щасливий».
Вже збирається їхати, бачу,
що хоче запитати, підходжу.
А вона знову: «Ти щасливий?»
«Ну щасливий я!
Невже тільки в Черкасах, Києві чи у Львові
можна бути щасливим?»
Ми живемо в раю.
Тільки ми цього не бачимо.
А ганяємося за щастям.
Як то кажуть, людина за щастям біжить,
а воно поруч лежить.
Хлопець, дівчина — це все біля нас.
А ми думаємо: «Ось там, десь...»
А як же знайти себе у собі?
Не те, що я як всі.
Широка дорога веде усіх відомо куди,
і всі цією дорогою йдуть.
А вузенька дорога веде до Творця.
І її треба пройти. Вона тяжка, складна,
але вузенька і людина там сама йде.
А не з усіма разом: «Усі так робили!
Всі так співали, всі так танцювали,
всі так скульптури робили!»
♪ [лунає повільна мелодія
на духовому та ударному інструментах] ♪
Для того, щоб щось створити,
потрібна любов.
Нема любові — не будеш
ні вишивати, ні малювати.
Всі війни — то прояв нелюбові.
Вони одурманені пропагандою,
не знають, що роблять.
Ти собою займись.
Як ти виріс духовно?
Що у тебе сталося?
Тоді й війни не буде.
«А де ж любов? У мене любові нема».
Якщо від тебе посилу любові нема,
то й до тебе вона нізвідки не прийде.
Вона не відгукнеться.
Як та луна.
Ми заграли — і луна пішла в лісі.
Спочатку має бути посил,
а тоді будуть зміни.
♪ [лунає повільна мелодія
на духовому та ударному інструментах] ♪
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]